all right cool so her face for me it
wasn't that long it's like
for when I was thinking like 14 got over
enough relationship started dipping
around and then I very quickly noticed
that I kind of had it easy with girls
so then I was just like all right cool I
don't need to be chasing like everyone
else likes doing and it was kind of like
a stereotype that was put on top of me
that I was gonna get someone pregnant
when I was young
so then I did the opposite and kind of
flipped it and I was just like you know
what I got options let me take my time
yeah pick who I want and then move from
there at least that way I know that
whoever's with me is not with me for the
success I'm gonna have
obviously this is me at 15. I don't want
to I knew that I was gonna end up being
in a good place in the future but I knew
that who I wanted by my side would be
someone that I knew was there for me and
not for the resources I can provide
exactly and that's a good choice that's
what you need with the right intentions
for you masculine thinking hey for me
how long was your whole face
it wasn't long it was like a year a year
a year and what what stood out about
your wife that made you pick her you
know what there was a few things some
things that I was keep keep on the Reps
but it was very clear to see from the
get-go that she was gonna be there for a
long time and especially with the stuff
that I do outside of that professional
life she's so something that he doesn't
I'm so sorry my love that I'm
interrupting you but something that he
doesn't want to say in front of people
just not to
um he's a stripper no no it's just not
too um not to embarrass my family
um just out of respect which I
appreciate is but I don't mind saying it
is because
um we had a problem with race so my
family didn't accept him being black and
I chose him over my family and we moved
out so I think from a very young age we
were like 16. he knew that okay [ __ ]
like she's she's like he was so close
with his family like his mum his aunties
his grandparents and I can't imagine
someone standing he broke up with me
like three times I was like hell no he's
I was showing up outside this house I
was like don't look me in the ass tell
me you don't love me and then I'll leave
and he couldn't do it she proved it and
I think and I think that was the biggest
thing I'm shaking I'm shaking guys
we didn't want to go too deep you you go
back answer your question no my mind's
bunny on an impressions
uh mine started when I think I lost my
Virginia when I was 14 early when I just
turned 14. and I would say it went on
four until I was about
um like seven years to tell us about 21
but I went home in the whole seven years
I was like
you might be obviously attracted a lot
of girls and because I was popular in my
area and I chilled with a lot of people
and that was popular and was obviously
just going parties and just that the man
on the party whatever
there will be a couple months in where I
won't even do nothing of a girl and
it'll be like maybe five months where
I'm just doing I'm just going crazy and
then yeah like when I hit about 21 22
kind of started to chill down and then
my mind kind of got a bit stronger I was
like I don't mean you need to do that
you kind of because you got used to it
it's like you don't really need to do
that and then you just kind of want to
look for someone
if you know what I mean yeah literally
so about seven years how bills seven
years
me yeah
um I don't know I don't even really like
I don't even really like to call what
men do a whole phase I don't really
think it's a whole I mean okay okay but
we could say they're Wild Oats yeah come
on bro
can we just deal with the reality yeah
yeah
um no
um I guess like I said probably like my
brother when I lost my virginity and um
you know you kind of know from seeing
how women interact with other men where
you kind of sit in the Spectrum and I
was like I didn't really have problems
sleeping with women you know I mean
coming up as as a young as a young guy
so I guess my my whole face is paused
when I was in relationships like I've
been in like three serious serious
relationships in my whole life and in
those in those periods I proactively try
to be you know everything that you would
want in that relationship but because
the people who I was with didn't make
that same commitment it just fell
through so like you know if I found
something like your wife but she's
pulling up outside your house I probably
would have been you know more inclined
to actually ride it out and the person I
actually had the the longest and the
deepest relationship with was somebody
who proactively pursued me as well in a
sense you see what I'm saying whereas
everybody else I kind of you know made
them my girlfriend type stuff you know I
mean because again I make that choice so
I don't know I don't think I don't think
I have I don't think I've left I'm
single now so I'm you know I guess I'm
back yeah
uh probably
about two or three years because so lost
my virginity in second year of uni which
is extremely late but I didn't I didn't
really like people in school so everyone
was dumb I didn't understand the reason
to get in relationships I thought they
were vacuous these guys running around
talking about who they whose hand they
held and then there was a there was a
town bike over there and it was just
dumb I was like I don't understand and I
still don't really understand much
relationship like what what why should I
like spend so much time talking and
building up some emotional relationship
um especially when you know if it ends
then you're distracted for like two
months until you reset or whatever so
uni
I've always been extremely picky though
so maybe a whole for me is different but
I've I have high standards of myself so
I like the idea that like some guys will
sleep with someone because she's up for
it it's disgusting to me it's like no no
so it's not me sleeping with youth
you're also sleeping with me in that so
you're also in my space my energy and
that's kind of nasty if you just pick
anyone that's disgusting especially if
women who kind of are like that tend to
be not very picky in general I'm not
narcissistic enough to believe that like
I'm special but this this girl in the
club saw me and realized that I had an
aura and wanted to know is she's
probably gotten with the other three
Nigerian guys so so I've a follow-up
question do you guys feel like
um
men end up with the girl that met them
at the right time
like that was there when they were done
with their whole face and ready to
settle down or the or the woman that
they love the most the one that I think
the one that met them because I was in
my sons that's for nine years and he's
ended up with the one that kind of he
cheated and then he cheated and she then
was like the last cheat
if that makes sense so that he cheated
on each person with each person and then
he's ended up with the one that would
and maybe she accepted it that's weird
um so what what are you I was that so
guys what do you what do you think I
think it depends on the guy and where
their headspace is at because I mean I
know that I'm an anomaly so I can't
really talk for all guys but as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible